le musée d'art moderne de la ville de
paris fête ses soixante années
d'existence avec une exposition
consacrée à l'art des années 30 les
oeuvres de l'époque vous allez le voir
témoigne de cette période qui précéda le
déclenchement de la deuxième guerre
mondiale georges bégoux jean-louis
poussèrent on ne faisait pas de
skateboard il y à 60 ans sur le parvis
du musée d'art moderne on inaugurait en
queue de pie et en os x à cette époque
là on vénérait celles qui changent et la
vie et engendrer le progrès la fée
électricité à laquelle le peintre duffy
consacrer le plus grand tableau du monde
600 mètres carrés ces années 30 où l'art
prend un air de liberté et s'affranchit
de la représentation académique des
objets de la nature ces années 30
commence mal
la planète est secouée par le krach
boursier de new york en 1929 et elle
voit s'écrouler des fortunes et des
idéaux
en europe les artistes témoignent de la
gravité de la crise qui a franchi
l'atlantique et étrangers spectre hante
leurs tableaux
pour la fin ces grèves ces marches de
chômeurs c'est une action ce n'est pas
une désespérance c'est une tentative de
faire quelque chose et qui débouche sur
quelque chose de très positif les
vacances payées accordée par le
gouvernement ont rendu cette année aux
plages de france toutes leurs animations
d'autres francs la victoire du front
populaire en 36 apparaît comme une zone
claire dans cette période sombre semaine
de 40 heures exaltation du sport qui
inspire quelques chefs-d'oeuvre
c'est la belle époque du vel d'hiv stade
qui deviendra quelques années plus tard
le lieu tragique de la rafle qui porte
son nom
pendant ce temps de l'autre côté du rhin
d'autres athlètes se préparent dont la
pureté de la race est glorifiée par les
peintres hitlérien en italie mussolini
anime lui aussi les fêtes de la jeunesse
qui ne laisse aucun doute sur les
intentions du dictateur duch est lui
aussi trouve des peintres à sa dévotion
les autres fui le fascisme et se
retrouve à paris beaucoup d'artistes du
monde entier s'en tenir à son art il y
avait un lot qui kate ellis à cette
époque là qui a qualifiant certains
arrêts qui est très beau qu'est la
notion d'art en dépendant aussi bien
dans le domaine du réalisme dans le
domaine de la traction
évidemment dit sir alice dali et miro
ont quitté l'espagne où la guerre civile
fait rage
picasso traduira dans le guernica la
sauvagerie de cet affrontement entre
républicains et fascistes on en voit ici
des études
hitler qui ne voulait voir qu'une seule
tête déclare va dégénérer les peintres
dérangeant des artistes embarqué jean un
nouveau radeau de la méduse et auquel on
rend hommage au musée d'art moderne